what's up guys I'm here with bhuvan bum
BB key vines how good am I at that oh
you're wonderful so good but he's
amazing you guys I'm sure you know him
from YouTube he does these awesome skits
and impressions and I love it it's like
you're your own SNL with your own
characters yeah fun but we're bringing
the world together guys yeah and give it
in the house and we got the us though we
are gonna do rapid fire because we're
limited on time today so we're just
gonna do a rapid-fire Q&A so it has to
be like back-to-back we just have to ask
question answer Alex go go go and what's
your favorite Bollywood actor
okay which is your favorite Hollywood
actress Angelina Jolie what's your
favorite color
all right which is your car DJ
Volkswagen you don't like I don't like
pork okay sister reminds me of high
school okay what is your favorite thing
to wear
what type of underwear do you my full of
ventilation
which was a forced brand endorsement on
vine when yeah that was like the first
one you've probably seen all the time
what is your favorite place to go in the
world I wanna go to Europe and I love is
it Amsterdam in Europe but I finally I'm
here with you watching this
so there's this a small ask BB in which
people ask me questions so in the first
in the first question of in the first
episode of ask BB people ask me with
your crush and I said - L mean you guys
became friends that's why you're good
you're good
hug it out brotherly love there you go
and now we dressed like this because we
just shot an awesome video and learned
some hindi and it is hard is really hard
this charcoal was real nice you could
see what you do thank you
if the go take you 40
Berryman make botanique emoji
Shuji group are we
- 18 full silicic shuttle allahu
chimeric emoji or scan Americana she
Ganga Prasad
hamaji
up morose lolly keema burning
[Music]
op akela Leakey bought some Copic
onomatopoeic emoji got shivved in each
aha ahaaa local nine left I D G B G mine
she hasn't seen a single video I don't
know everybody just different stuff like
I love watching how to learn a lot so
which is your favorite in certain
occasions I don't mean to sorry I mean
I'm biased but I love that was great
he's really funny you know skiddo memes
i love mean pages to it a second oh and
um what is the food one where's the cola
how many if you're getting this it's
like all those really cool recipes and
stuff I don't know I follow doc he's
someone she's a cutie good actress
yeah what's her name rocky she is
gorgeous and she speaks better Hindi
than I do
yes she does but look at me I'm trying
they were there
today and into the flower and this I
don't know what I'm wearing basically
wearing pajamas look into my shoes so
alright so that's the video it's pretty
basic but it's our relationship and it's
us getting to know each other more and
then hopefully I get you to come to LA
more people watching this video comes to
Indian and really want you to come to
India is an invitation yes cheaper one
like I see the audience always moving
out like inviting me in my fans and
stuff and I'm like yeah but who am I
gonna go see you when I'm out there
exactly people in India they love you
everything and the day I posted a
picture on Instagram
it blew our minds you so much love for
Vidya it's insane people love it that
you must come easy okay and then you
have to come back to the way done deal
this is a deal is happening we're gonna
plan it out and we're gonna make it epic
and we're gonna we should do like
something really cool though like with
the fans and liquid job figure out some
really cool and something unique which
no one has ever done before so we're
you're gonna do alright you have to pick
three last questions to ask me questions
that you really wouldn't want to know
okay so this is a really risky question
and people watching this they always
wanted to ask me if John wasn't in your
life and I would have asked you out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right mine would be how do you deal
with all you know patrols online and all
the hate comments do you get a lot of
hate comments or I'm sure you have a
huge show fans are super supportive and
even a better way is to be friends with
them that's what you need is to like
sometimes I'll reply like nice things
than their move completely such as they
won't disturb in Shu yeah that's what I
have noticed but I don't think we should
do we should we should focus more on
people who love us
yeah sure because I you know and now I
only focus on the positive comments
inside and it's so much better and it's
and life is much better than if you only
focus on positive things yeah because
people who love you are very more
numbered and people so I'm not after you
done with your biggest dream after you
achieve everything what's that one thing
you wanna do as your retirement plan see
that's hard because I loved working and
I feel like that is fun for me and
that's probably why I'm being successful
in what I'm doing
please Shea answer but it's true like
I'll get bored if I'm just sitting on a
beach all day and I love the beach what
if what after you lose all your teeth
yeah when I don't have teeth I'm gonna I
think I'm going to
I love the beach I like I need to be by
the water so I think I'm gonna be just
chilling on the beach some beaches
beyond sovereignty yeah and then I can
be at Pattaya yes so I will be on the
beach without tea eating dragon fruit
because it's a machine and you don't
need to do that
and figs cuz I love pigs I'll just be
eating and sunbathing that should really
go
yeah just eat so I noticed obviously
your name is bebe keen minds yeah
and I understand the bb4 move on yeah
she is apostrophe s and then the vines
part like you don't so plain so I don't
know how it happened I used to follow
and from there I got the word minds and
while I was creating my page on Facebook
they asked me what you wanna name it so
then I came up with bebe - proven wrong
keywords so bad just like your
inspiration for your name I think yes
that's we have to get you invest
together I'll give you the last thing
it's not a question it's it's a task for
you and it's a famous famous saying it's
a famous proverb in in the it's a to
stability okay so it's going
John Luke each on its own will be
charged you could charm a joke meeting
each other once the chat which I may do
a little Chinese ciaochao ciaochao
change
[Applause]
okay Chandu okay hey Johnny
chatter named Chandu Chandu kee keep
chachi chachi ho Chandan me rock me
Charlotte John the Meera me sandy did
lab to me
Chandni Chandni rot that's hard yeah
right
me me John Deacon John much time DCAM
much see see
check me check me checking I think I
know that let me just be that up so it
sounds like it yeah go channel to me
brats me child
Tiki Cho much sea jet me alright last
question what has been your favorite
food to eat while in the United States
something you don't like the food no and
what I don't like the Mexican food I
don't know cuz we be opinions are really
you to spices love you used to the
spices flavor I know a fellow Vedic
possible oh you cut up your over it
there's some good places not
down but like the pasta here I noticed
when I was in Italy it was so fresh and
so good an egg wouldn't gain weight
evening the clock stuff but eating the
pasta here it's like the opposite of
that and then what is typically oh hey
see ya people here love Chipotle and
they love the means of Chipotle this
quick and easy it's not the Mexican food
that you were talking about I don't know
I just I just find his name funny
Chipotle yeah in India
Chipotle sounds like a Marathi nickname
Chipotle th move just wait
I'm gonna take you to some places live
in a polymer and be like okay video like
that please give it a thumbs up comment
below what you want to see us to me next
way if it's like a movie nope it's
another skin if it's the Q&A I could be
as like backup dancer I don't know but
let us know comment below and make sure
you turn on those notifications that
little building somewhere so I'll see
you later
and
[Music]